okay so thanks very much for inviting me
so I'll describe the goals of this talk
on the next slide I want to develop
algorithms and hardness results for
classical linear algebra problems this
talk is based on a few works with Ken
Clarkson and also interesting
discussions that I had with a mirror Wu
Yu ting I are tres Becker's and Richard
Peng there's a part of the talk that is
still like work in progress and that's
what these discussions are about so sort
of the status is we have many algorithms
for in reductions between graph problems
string problems we've seen a lot of
problems in this workshop such as all
pair shortest paths finding triangles
etc and the goal of this talk is to ask
the question is can we do the same thing
for linear algebra problems ok so what
are some problems that that people study
so some classical optimization problems
one is regression so given an N by D
matrix a typically n is much larger than
D the 12th in matrix and an N by 1
vector B find a vector X which minimizes
the norm of ax minus B ok where you can
look at various different norms if i
take the euclidean norm this is the
least squares problem so you know ax
gives you the closest vector in the
column span of a two to be no so this is
in polynomial time but how quickly can
you find such an X another question is a
low-rank approximation so given an N by
D matrix a and an integer parameter K
output a rank K matrix B which is as
close as possible to a under some norm
ok and we'll look at a few different
norms in this talk you could ask even
more basic questions so what is the
complexity of the following problems
suppose I'm given a symmetric n by n
binary matrix a and I wanted to output
and added
one over poly an approximation to each
of its eigenvalues ok so it's symmetric
it's n by n its binary so you have
bounds you know you have worst-case
bounds on the eigenvalues you know what
is the complexity of this problem so the
output description here is just n log n
bits can I do it in linear time to
describe a you could also ask a relative
error version of this given an n-by-n
matrix a and integer K what if I want a
multiplicative to approximation to its
Kate singular value so here the output
do you know is really tiny right it's
just the two approximation to a number
with and we call the single values of
the square roots of the eigenvalues of a
transpose a so what is like a complexity
of this problem ok so the outline of the
talk is as follows I'll first show how
you can solve a number of linear algebra
problems in time which is proportional
to the time just to describe the input
so we shouldn't have hardness and these
come by reduction so they what what they
do is they they take say an instance of
regression and they reduce the problem
very quickly in input description time
to a smaller version of itself ok and
this is what i like to call like a
sketch in solve paradigm so i'll go over
low-rank approximation and then variants
of that robusta link approximation and
the second part of the talk is more you
know sort of work in progress so it's a
notion of lowering approximation called
spectral low-rank approximation and here
I think there should be a hardness so ok
so let me just go over low-rank
approximation you're given an N by D
matrix a and think of the n rows of a as
being points in our d
for example a might be a customer
product matrix and a IJ might indicate
how many times customer i purchased item
J in many cases a is well approximated
by a low rank matrix okay so it might
only be high rank because of noise that
was added to the system and so the goal
is to find a low rank approximating a
it's easy to store a low rank matrix in
factored form it can make your data more
interpretable etc okay so what is a good
low-rank approximation so we call the
singular value decomposition the SVD
that any matrix a can be written as the
product of three matrices use sigma and
v where you has orthonormal columns
sigma is diagonal with the entries are
decreasing as i go down the diagonal and
V has orthonormal rose okay so one way
of getting a low-rank approximation say
rank k approximation is just to truncate
this diagonal matrix Sigma okay so I
take the top K entries of Sigma I leave
them alone and I zero out the remaining
entries and this corresponds to
selecting the K leftmost vectors of you
and the K uppermost vectors of V that's
a rank K matrix and so I approximate a
by this and I get some error matrix here
so why do that well oh by the way the so
the rows of VK here are called the top k
principal components um so why do that
well this matrix this rain k
approximation denoted a sub K is
actually the the best rank K
approximation to a under many different
norms in particular under the Frobenius
norm just the entry wise Euclidean norm
of the matrix okay so this is you know
the optimal solution and the SVD can be
computed in part
niall time in particular in the minimum
of n d squared + n squared D time you
can do a bit better with fast matrix
multiplication but still it's quite
expensive okay so we really want
algorithms or we either want an
algorithm which runs in time
proportional to the time of describing
the input a or we want to maybe have
some conditional hardness for such a
problem so it turns out that if you
relax the problem by allowing for
approximation so now I output a rank K
matrix B so that's the norm of a minus B
is at most 1 plus epsilon times the best
possible then actually you can do much
better and you also allow a tiny
probability of failure you can get a
running time which is number of nonzero
entries of a nnz of a plus a typically
lower order term so n plus D times
polynomial and K epsilon okay so k is
the rank parameter is typically not too
large 1 over epsilon is also typically
not too large so so here this is really
an inputs partially time algorithm up to
these these lauder terms this was the
technique was sort of a sketch in salt
technique which was pioneer for this by
SAR lows and we were able to get better
at running time with Clarkson so let me
let me give you an idea how how to
achieve this running time for
approximate SVD
so the idea is as follows so you're
giving this M by the input matrix a you
think of having these endpoints in rd
and the first step is what you do is you
compute s times a ok where s is a random
matrix there are many different kinds of
random matrices s that work I'll go over
some of those i'll call the sketching
matrix S & S what it is is it's a very
wide fat matrix okay so it has k over
epsilon rows and n columns and so what s
times a is doing is it's taking k
epsilon random linear combinations of
the points these endpoints and i can
look at the rows of s times a as a sub
space in our d which i've drawn here is
a line and the next step of the
algorithm is to take the endpoints the
rows of a and project them on to this
space s times a ok so i protect them the
closest point in s times a and now what
do i do i do the SVD in this lower
dimensional space okay so i had these
end points in our d we said the SVD was
very inefficient what i'm going to do is
protect them onto a very low dimensional
space and then now i can afford to
compute the SVD exactly because the
dimension is k r epsilon will be like NK
r epsilon squared time so let me so the
first natural question is which matrices
s work so that if i do this procedure
i'll get a 1 plus epsilon approximation
so a 1 natural family of matrices is
just a matrix of iid normal random
variables ok if i choose cave r epsilon
rose then you can show that if i do this
procedure i'll get a 1 plus epsilon
approximation ok but there's a problem
with choosing such an s ok yeah so the
problem is that
s is a very dense matrix so computing s
times a itself won't give you time
proportional to the time to describe the
input okay so in a very nice paper of
Thomas Arles he showed that instead s
can be a cave r epsilon by n fast
Johnson lindenstraße matrix ok and this
uses algorithms for fft and so now
actually you can compute s times a in
time which is roughly n times d which is
I mean up to a log n factor which is
optimal for dense matrices however it's
still not you know input description
time does this this method can't exploit
the fact if your input matrix a is
sparse so what we showed is that instead
if s is a poly cave revlon by n count
sketch matrix then this approach the
sketch in solve paradigm using this s
still works so here the number of rows
is slightly larger think of poly killer
epsilon is being k epsilon squared but
still this goes into the lower a low
order term the yes the nice thing about
this count sketch matrix is that it's
very sparse okay so what it is is so I
have these n columns and in each column
I have a single nonzero entry chosen at
a uniformly random position and i put 1
or minus 1 on that log location or with
equal probability ok so the point here
is that s times a can now be computed in
input sparsity time yeah so why do you
call this a count sketch matrix or why
is it called that because no no it's
just from it's a matrix that's used in
the datastream literature and it's so it
came from the datastream literature and
they're what they're doing is estimating
heavy items they're counting these
things so we just have something
mostly zeros and then a few pluses and
minuses yeah so to say it again each
column independently you have a single
nonzero entry and on that entry you put
1 or minus 1 with equal probability yeah
and and so s times they can be computed
in in n + Z of a time yeah that's good
okay so okay so it let me go over the
current algorithm for lower-income Fox
emotion because there's still a caveat
so what did we say we're going to do
we're given this n by D matrix a we
compute s times a using the count sketch
matrix we can do this in input sparsity
time the next step we said is let's
project each of the rows the endpoints
of a on to s times a so it's not clear
how to do that in input sparsity time
let's get back to that and the final
step is once all these points these
endpoints are inside the best times a
now we can afford to do the SVD inside
of that low dimensional space okay and
so this is this is efficient this is
like n times Polly care epsilon okay so
yeah the bottleneck is step 2 so how do
you project these points on to s times a
so what we can do instead is we can
approximate this projection itself so
and for this we use a fast algorithm for
approximate regression so let me just
recast the problem as follows so what
the theory is guaranteed is that the
space the rows of s times a contain a
good K dimensional space in there span
so i know that if i solve this
optimization problem the minimum over
ranked k matrices x of the norm of x x
SI minus a i'll get a good rank a
approximation but why should i solve
this exactly i mean this is an instance
of regression i can solve it using
approximate regression right so i
already know that if i solve for the
optimal x will get a 1 plus epsilon a
box
mission and if I instead get an
approximation to this I'll get a 1 plus
epsilon squared approximation okay so
that's the idea to find this approximate
solution it's a it's a reduction of a
regression problem to a smaller instance
of regression so we instead output this
X prime which is ranked k and so that
the cost of X prime si minus a is at
most 1 plus epsilon times the optimal
cost and we do it in much the same way
so we choose a random matrix call it R
which will be account sketch matrix it's
d by poly cave or epsilon so it's we're
going to be multiplying on the right so
it's d by something small we take our
space s times a and we compute s times a
times R we take a and we compute a times
R and now we instead solve this much
smaller instance of regression okay so
what we do is we replace sa with SAR and
a with AR and now we find the x prime
which minimizes this expression okay and
let me mention that if R is this count
sketch matrix you can compute s times
they are in and a times R in number of
nonzero entries of a time the reason is
that sa the number of nonzero entries of
sa is also at most the number of nonzero
entries of a so this can all be done
efficiently and now that you have a
small problem you can actually solve
this exactly in n times poly caver
epsilon time ok so just to summarize the
overall time for low-rank approximation
is input sparsity time plus n plus
deepali k epsilon ok any questions about
this
okay okay so let me move on now to a
robust low-rank approximation here we
have both inputs parsa time algorithms
and we have hardness conditional
hardness assuming ETH so first what is
the problem so this SVD is a little bit
sensitive to outliers right so we have
these endpoints in our d and we're
trying to find a low dimensional space
which minimizes the sum of squared
distances to it if we have one point
which is a little bit far further away
since we're squaring these distances we
actually have to pay a lot of attention
to it and so then our space sort of
shifts towards that point and we capture
less of this you know the less of the
remaining low dimensional structure so a
natural thing to do you know try to come
up with a more robust cost measure
what's one property you might want of
this measure so one is that if you take
your endpoints in rd and you rotate rd
that the cost is preserved but it seems
like you might want something that only
depends on the geometry of these points
as opposed to penalizing for some
particular basis that you might choose
so yes if I have this rotation matrix W
and I get these rotated n rows of away I
want the same cost so what's a natural
cost function that generalizes the SVD
well it's it's the following so or one
of them is the following so instead of
finding the best K dimensional space
which minimizes the sum of squared
distances I minimize the sum of P powers
of distances of my points to a subspace
where P is a parameter and note that
this is rotationally invariant I mean
these are Euclidean distances if I
rotate the space this this cost function
is preserved um the nice thing though is
that if I choose P to be less than 2
this is more robust than the SVD in the
sense that i described right so I'm not
squaring this
instances in particular for P equals one
is a question that might even be
arguably more fundamental than the SVD
I'm just trying to find the subspace
which minimizes the sum of distances of
my points to that space okay okay so
what is known about this so just let me
say notationally so 1 plus epsilon
approximation for a space V prime means
if i plug it into this objective
function I get 1 plus epsilon relative
error so what's known for any p at least
one I can find a 1 plus epsilon
approximation in time which is n times d
poly caver epsilon plus an exponential
term in poly over epsilon okay so there
the first thing that might strike you is
that you know there's an exponential
term here and is it necessary another
thing is the leading you know if K and
epsilon are small or cave reps on a
small this leading order term you might
also want input description time as
opposed to ND poly caver epsilon 1 way
of handling this exponential term is to
relax the problem and instead output
what's known as a week corset so all
this is saying is instead of outputting
AK dimensional space which is a 1 plus
epsilon approximation I'll put a
slightly larger dimensional space ok so
I output a poly k r epsilon dimensional
space which contains a good K
dimensional space in its span we just
don't know how to find it if you allow
this relaxation then you can get rid of
this exponential term so this
exponential term is really coming from
the fact that you don't know which K
dimensional space to choose inside of
this week corset so you can get n times
d poly k rep salon you still might want
input description time for p greater
than 2 which is not the focus of this
talk because this is
is not this doesn't correspond to a
robust version of the SVD this is
actually making the power is larger the
problem is np-hard to approximate up to
a fixed constant factor depending on p
this is work by deshpande at all and
guru Swami at all and there's a nearly
matching constant approximation factor a
polynomial time algorithm okay so it so
our results for this problem what we
show is that for any p less than two
there is an algorithm which achieves
input sparsity time plus n plus the
polychaete rep salon Plus this
exponential term and actually this
exponential term we will show is
necessary I'll mention in a second so it
if you just want a week corset you can
get rid of the exponential term and then
you'll get a running time which is very
similar to what it was for the SVD okay
so input sparsity time plus n plus
deepali caver epsilon um well we show is
there is assuming the exponential time
hypothesis there is an n to the K time
lower bound if epsilon is 1 over d ok so
what this means is interpreting this you
can't actually get an algorithm which is
polynomial and all the parameters nd K +
1 over epsilon so you know but we don't
know if the problem is still hard of
epsilon is a fixed constant so that's an
open question i'll mention again later
but at least you know it suggests that i
can't sort of completely get rid of this
exponential term
we can generalize this to a large class
of low-rank approximation problems
instead of minimizing finding a K
dimensional space which minimizes the
sum of peace powers you can imagine sort
of general functions of your distances
and for class of functions we can get
similar running times I'll just briefly
go over the algorithm for the case of P
equals 1 when I'm taking the sum of
distances okay so let's try to follow
the intuition that we had for the
approximate SVD getting this input
sparsity time the first step is was to
try to get a low dimensional space which
contains a good K dimensional space
inside of it this makes all the
computations more efficient so for the
SVD we just computed s times a whereas
was a random matrix we don't have such a
thing for some of distances okay we
don't have a distribution on random
matrices which or we don't know of one
which gives us similar properties so we
don't really have this first step what
we do have is the following statement
which is a segment of the following form
so there's a there's a set of
probabilities P 1 through P n such that
if for each of the N rows of a these
endpoints I independently decide to
include each row in a sample with that
probability so I include the ITA with
property P I then the samples that I get
will contain a good K dimensional space
in its span now there are some caveats
first the sum of these probabilities is
polynomial and K so the expected number
of samples i'll get by this procedure
will be polynomial and k moreover the
guarantee is not that this space that I
get contains a good 1 plus epsilon
approximation the guarantees that it
contains a much cruder poly k
approximation but we'll be able to
bootstrap given
such a course approximation so there
exists these probabilities so what we
want to do this fast so the time to find
these probabilities you know the
previous best algorithm was n times
Pauly D okay which is not so exciting so
it turns out that will use sketching
again this you know reducing the problem
to a smaller instance of itself to find
these probabilities much faster so let
me just give you an idea for the the
overall algorithm so the first step of
the algorithm is to replace a with a
times R okay where r is a account sketch
matrix this reduces you know the matrix
from being an x d2n by poly ok r epsilon
ok and now you know we said we need to
find these probabilities and the time
was like n times dimension to the fifth
or I didn't say exactly what it was n
times polynomial in dimension time now
what do you imagine the next step is so
the next step is instead of creating
these probabilities based on a we create
these properties based on a times R
where the dimension the number of
columns of a times R is much smaller
these probabilities by the way if you've
seen it before they're called the l1
leverage scores I mean just the term to
keep in mind but this step is now
efficient so now i can create these in n
times poly k reps long time
and now where did we say the next step
was once we have these probabilities we
can sample so we sample the rows of a
according to these probabilities that we
found from a times R we get some sample
set S which was a very crude
approximation if you remember always
said is it contains a poly k
approximation in its span but now
there's a bootstrapping procedure called
adaptive sampling which is we're going
to additionally sample more rows more
points of a as follows we're going to
look at each of the rows and we're going
to compute its distance to our current
sample set okay so P sub s here means
the projection onto the current sample
set and so for given row ai- aips that
Euclidean norm is the distance to my set
my current set of samples and
intuitively we should be sampling points
with higher probability the further that
they are away from this space so these
are the points that we're not capturing
so far and this works so if I
additionally sample a settee of poly
cave reps on rows of a proportional to
their distance to the crude sample set
then actually I can guarantee that now
this new set s union t will contain a
good 1 plus epsilon approximation now
you might be wondering you know how do I
actually compute these probabilities as
we said it's not efficient to project of
these points onto a space what we do the
same kind of thing as before ok so we
approximate each of these residuals
again using sketching ok so we can set
up these kinds of regression problems as
I said that we did for the SVD and so we
can an input sparsity time actually find
the sample set and finally the last step
is the step where the exponential in k
rep salon term comes from so
once you have this set your crude
samples s and your adaptively chosen
samples T you need to find the best K
dimensional space inside of the span of
the Union and so one way of doing this
is to set up a system of polynomial
inequalities and run a generic
polynomial system solver and that gives
you an exponential in caver epsilon time
however as I said if you if you don't
like that term you can stop at step 4 if
you just want a week corset because at
this point your guarantee that s Union
teak contains a good K dimensional space
in its span okay so that's the the idea
here and the same the same basic
framework applies to these other loss
functions and the overall time is input
sparsity time plus n plus D poly k r
epsilon plus an exponential term for the
last step in k epsilon any any questions
about this algorithm
okay okay so okay so so let me now move
on to spectra low-rank approximation and
here this is just some discussions and
some you know some questions that I have
for this community so first so unlike
these forms of low-rank approximation we
don't have optimal algorithms so
returning to some of the questions in
the beginning the first question is that
I had is how much time is needed to
output simultaneously for every I an
approximation AI to the eigen value of a
say up to additive one over poly n ya a
was a symmetric n by n matrix yes yeah
sorry a is symmetric n by n matrix yeah
constraints let's say it's a binary
matrix yeah yeah so I mean this is a so
I like what are some conditional lower
bounds for this problem any suggestions
I mean so I think these problems might
might be very canonical for linear
algebra so here's you know something
that is just just just something so
suppose I take a to be in adjacency
matrix of a graph and I had all these
approximations eii for each of the
eigenvalues then what is the trace of a
cubed this is the sum of the cubes of
the eigenvalues and what else does the
trace of a cubed indicate what indicates
I can count the number of triangles in
the graph and what is the best known
algorithm we have four counting
triangles I mean even if matrix
multiplication is exponent is 2 so
basically the best know now that my know
is n NZ of a to the Four Thirds right so
this is saying something that you know
so yeah I mean so but but maybe there's
something much better here and maybe
you'll solve it in the next 10 minutes
I'll let me know another question is I
had this relative error question so
given a integer value K how much time is
needed to output a number E which is a
two approximation to the kate singular
value of a let's say the entries of a
are again bounded maybe 0 1 minus 1 any
ideas like how hard this problem is and
this is actually important problem
because the spectral low-rank
approximation actually can be used to
solve this problem so I now get to the
definition of that in a second
cigna case oh sorry yeah so Sigma K is
the Kate Singler value of a so it's the
case so i think a transpose a and i look
at its eigenvalues and it's the square
root of the case eigenvalue any ideas on
this like should this be a hard problem
okay so here's one thing I mean it's
it's just something I wouldn't call the
solution it's definitely not but let's
say I take a to be the top matrix of a
graph on on K nodes okay so remember the
top matrix like okay so it's it's like
the adjacency matrix but instead of you
know if I have an edge between I&J I
don't have a one and A one in the I J
and J aight entry i have a one and a
minus one okay well if i take the top
matrix of a graph on K nodes then if I
had such an e that subset of such an
approximation I could determine if that
matrix was full rank right because you
know I'm distinguishing between zero and
non-zero and then the graph has a
perfect matching if and only if the the
rank of the top matrix if it's a full
rank matrix okay so these are like some
and the best known algorithm for this
matching problem is the minimum of
energy of a times root K and n NZ of a
plus k2 the Omega time which gives some
kind of super linear lower bounds when K
is is large but I mean this is basically
just saying that you know computing the
rank of a matrix you know we don't have
the is hard like what I'd really like to
understand here is maybe not
distinguishing 0 from non zero but
distinguishing you know a single
positive singular value from twice that
value okay so let me just say what
spectralink approximation is what the
open question is so suppose a is an
n-by-n matrix now I want to find the
rain k matrix B for which the operator
norm of a minus B is small okay so
remember the operator norm of matrix is
the supremum of our unit vectors of the
length of the matrix e is the length of
C times X this is the largest single
value of a minus B so now what I want is
this to be at most 1 plus epsilon times
the k plus first single value of a okay
so let me just say that you know I'm
approximating a by a rank a matrix be
the best thing to do would be to choose
B to align with the top casing the
values of a and then i would get error
which is the k plus first single value
of a and now i'm relaxing that problem
in asking you for one plus epsilon
approximation
okay so and this this can give much
stronger guarantees and for Venus norm
low-rank approximation imagine if I
matrix is diagonal and it has a two and
a bunch of ones okay then there's no
there's no really good rank one
approximation in frobenius norm because
since this I have so many ones like 1
plus epsilon times this tale I can just
output the 0 matrix for low-rank
approximation with respect to those
earlier cost measures that I discussed
but for this spectral low rank
approximation I really need to notice
that there's a two here okay because I
really need to reduce the operator norm
of this matrix from two down to 1 plus
epsilon so this is just an example where
it's much more powerful okay so what is
known about this how do i compute a
spectral low-rank approximation so the
algorithm I mean is classical it's just
the power method but since we're
computing a ring k approximation its k
fold power method so let me say what
that is so that QB login over epsilon
it's the number of iterations of the
power method you computer matrix B which
is G times a to the q where g is a k by
n matrix of iid normal random variables
okay so how do you compute this where
you first compute G times a and then you
get a new k by n matrix then you can
prove G times a times a and you do that
Q times ok and it doesn't matter if you
choose say like account sketch matrix or
some other faster matrix G here because
after you run this a few steps the
matrix is going to become dense this K
by n matrix that you're carrying along
the guarantee is you can show that at
the end you get this k by n matrix B and
the Rose span a 1 plus epsilon
approximation to the best
a low-rank approximation the time is K
times n NZ of a times log in or epsilon
so what I want to know is if K times n
NZ of a here is is necessary or not ok
for these other versions of low-rank
approximation we just got n NZ of a time
so one thing that archers and Amir
pointed out to me is if your matrix is
dense then actually you can use fast
yeah oh I just it's K times n NZ of a
times Q yeah I mean for this talk like
you think of it is like not important so
so one thing that was pointed out to me
is that if K is not too large say less
than n to the point 3 then there is an
algorithm that runs in a roughly n
squared time and it proceeds by doing
this algorithm but at each step using
fast rectangular matrix multiplication
to do the matrix multiplication ok using
say coppersmith or the gauls improvement
um ok but in general oh and so so in
general for dense matrices this is not
that far off from from from the best
possible right for sparse matrices we
still don't know anything better than k
and then Z of a or much better there was
very nice work by Musco Musco which
improved the epsilon dependence to to
root epsilon um but yeah in general the
question is can we achieve input
sparsity time plus n times polychaete
epsilon for this problem like we could
for the other lowering problems and I
should mention there is a reduction you
can reduce this problem in NZ of a + NK
time to the problem of approximating the
Kate Singler value of a matrix okay and
how hard
that problem should that be a canonical
problem okay so yeah okay so let me just
conclude so hardness in p for a number
of linear algebra problems does not seem
very well understood we saw that for
some classical problems you can actually
get optimal input sparsity time for
frobenius norm error and some robust
versions of low-rank approximation some
open questions that came out of this so
we're bus low-rank approximation as i
said we don't know if the problem is in
polynomial time for fixed approximation
error and growing k the dimension of the
subspace respect to a low-rank
approximation is there a conditional
lower bound say of n + z of a times k
when your matrix is say order n sparse i
have a recent monograph with a lot of
this material if you're interested and
that's all thank you questions
yeah I have that problem that you said
can count the number of triangles in the
draft yeah for it there is no the best
amalgam for counting the number of
triangles or oh the the problem for that
you mean just the problem of estimating
each of the eigenvalues up to yeah so in
general m it's basically this SVD time
so yeah it's much higher
any any other questions
alright so let's